foreign
what's up Joe
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call of course what's happening
um I have a quandary
um quandary oh that's a word that we've
never heard on the show I think this is
the first quandary excellent
there you go grab a nickel for that too
um
my quandary is my issue is I grew up
very Catholic very obedient without
contest that is fantastic very Catholic
okay yes and and you know like so you
are great at following rules and you do
not ask questions
no I exactly exactly that and it's
becoming an issue as an adult correct um
and it is it has turned me into a people
pleaser it has turned me into a little
sex sorry um success pursuing machine
that is always tired and it is ruining
my relationship with people is this is
this from church or is this from your
parents
I think it's a little of both to be very
honest okay
um
um my mom who is a wonderful lady she
raised me as a single woman
um my dad chose to leave
um I'm smiling here when you watch the
YouTuber you can see me laughing just
then anytime somebody says my mom she
was amazing and then there's always a
butt or like or my dad was so great but
I mean they're they're your first love
they're your first nurturers they're
your first interaction with everything
and they can also be your first abusers
and they can be your first person who
used you to make themselves feel better
about themselves it's all true at the
same time right yes it is okay and um my
father was an abusive individual and my
mother didn't want us growing around
um that in that kind of an environment
good for her so she left she immigrated
to the United States by herself with two
toddlers
so she's a tough strong woman right
you got that right okay you don't mess
with her
and um you know she and you know being
an adult I recognize the hardships of
that I recognize not knowing anybody and
taking your children and truly just
relying on your faith and your your
tenacity to work and your mind so as I
grew up and I got older I began to
question things as anybody does
um and I became skeptical about a lot of
things and it wasn't until very recently
I started realizing am I being obedient
or am I honoring my mother
um which is a big a big exhale but also
a big suspended breath in my chest
because it is one of the things that you
know I try to do I try to be a good
Christian person
but also try to live my life so
obedience and honor are not are not one
in the same
obedience and honor are mutually
exclusive here's what I mean
um when you're 10
and your mom says take out the trash
because you're a member of our household
and you play a role here too
honoring your mom is taking out the
trash
right um
if you're 13 and you come home and say
Dad I'm getting bullied and your dad
grabs you by the collar and says when
you walk into school tomorrow you get
off that bus you walk straight into the
lockers and you hit that kid in the
mouth as hard as you can
that is not honoring your dad by hitting
him it's acting like a child like he is
okay so
um one is obedience is honor one is
disobedience is not dead I'm not going
to go hit a kid in the mouth that's not
going to make this better
okay
or if
the opposite happens if my son witnessed
somebody another kid in his grade
beating up a girl in the hallway
I would fully expect him to intervene
that's what I've trained him to do right
to make sure people are safe
and so
all I have to say is this how old are
you now
I'm 28. okay
my guess is
mom had a very rigid way of doing life
because that's the only way she could
survive
that's the house you grew up in you also
grew up without a dad you've got a lot
of childhood trauma okay
and the the research on immigrant
parents and first-gen kids and all that
is both like really makes for really
sexy headlines and also those are scary
houses to grow up in
yes both in right it's cool to tell the
story like man my mom made it
whoo that was 20 years of whoa
and there's a lot of those stories that
don't get told or mom didn't make it
right so we know that you live through
that my guess is now Mama's starting to
tell you can continue to tell you how
you're living your life and what you
should be doing
and I'm your mom are you just gonna
disobey your mom
and the answer is honor in this case
the best way you can honor your mom is
to be well in whole
because she raised you to be fiercely
independent
to make hard choices to walk away when
you need to to work like nobody's
business with a work ethic
and that might mean telling her no I'm
not gonna do that this time I'm doing
something different
doing everything she says and getting
crucified is not uh honor
so give me an example of something she's
telling you to do that you don't want to
do anymore
oh this is this is wonderful
um because so far everything has been
so family centered I am the first born
in accordance you know birth order and
I'm also the oldest girl
um so the expectation to always take
care of people is something that I also
struggle with
um but recently I finished my second to
last semester of nursing school so I'm
entering that phase of my life
and she wants me to stay in our town
um which I don't want to do
I've lived here for 28 well close to 28
years 20 more so and I don't I don't
want to be here I feel that I have
callings to go elsewhere I feel like I
need to go I don't have Community here
yeah and I think if I was you I'd sit
down the conversation and say Mom at a
young age
um
you had to go and you had to go for an
abusive reason I've got to go for to go
make my mark
You Raised Me This Way
and I'm so grateful you gave me the
courage because a lot of people just
stay in their same small town and they
die there and you're saying time for me
to go
and that that departure will be met with
all kinds of I can't believe you're
abandoning your family what about this
that's about them it's probably because
you're such an amazing daughter
that your mom has come to rely on You
Like Oxygen right and she's a grown-up
and she's gonna have to find connections
there and this doesn't mean you're gone
forever
but it might mean we're gonna go make a
place for us and then I'll come back and
get you I I can mean any number of
things but I think you need to go
because here's what's gonna happen if
you don't
you're going to start to resent your mom
and I don't think she deserves that I
don't think you deserve that I don't
think your relationship deserves that
I agree and it can be a two-year thing
hey I'm gonna try this out for two years
and that might give your mom a little
dot dot give her an opportunity to grow
into it might give you an opportunity to
grow into it
and it doesn't sound so Eternal or so
forever but I think you need to make a
list of the things your mom's asking you
to do or demanding of you if you will
and walk through
probably with a close friend would be
best but to walk through these and say
okay
as I'm 28 years old I'm graduating
college I'm about to hit the market and
go see the world
um
how much of this stuff is honor and how
much of this is my mom just wants me
around
how much of this is cultural from the
old world to and I'm making some changes
in my personal life I'm adopting new
parts of new cultures and I'm gonna go
do x y and z
let's just choosing reality right it's
just owning it
no I'm telling you to do that what's the
feeling in your guts
like yes or is it oh no
I've tried to do that
um and
uh it was really hard because the
support system that I had gone to to get
counseling on it
um was a pastor of mine and I just they
knew that I was having issues with
identity they knew I was having issues
with being independent as an adult
should or or even just chart that what
that feels like and I remember sitting
down and telling her I think it's time
for me to go and she said oh it's
because of that new church that you
joined oh gosh you should have gone up
and walked out you should have got up
and walked out
oh my gosh like sit down with your
Barber and being like oh I see somebody
else cut your hair like what what are we
doing here yeah you see how that that
Pastor made your
Quest your adventure what comes next for
you your identity
all about her
it's not that's not how you do that you
sit down with somebody it's man I'm
sorry that happened to you
lucky for you you've got some
knuckleheaded uh podcaster that you've
never met I'll be sure to tell you no I
I mean I I think you gotta go I think
you gotta go I think you gotta go see
and I also think you got to be honest
with your mom I think you got to be
honest with you are gonna feel
incredibly guilty
and your mom probably wouldn't be your
mom if she didn't just lay it on super
thick
and if some of her friends and some of
your extended family members can't
believe you're abandoning everybody okay
but I think you need to go again I would
tell you let's go try this for two years
let's go try this for three years
and see what happens
so see what happens when we left Texas
and my wife and I left Texas um we left
our all of our family all of our friends
our whole thing and to move to Nashville
to work at at the University
um I said let's give this three years
and let's see what living in another
state another community and dude it's
been magic it's been awesome
so yeah I think it's time and and again
remember
doing every single solitary thing your
parents says even when you're 30 years
old that's not that's not
honor
living the life that they trained you to
live to the fullest
taking care of them when they need care
setting up support networks that they
can opt in or out of
I don't want to live there I want to
live here I can't afford there well then
you don't love me well I'm not taking
out a mortgage right
honor is a much bigger conversation than
I said so
go go see the world let me know when you
get there I want to hear how it goes
sounds like an adventure awaits